6 34. all right so as you know we are
heading into memorial day weekend the
unofficial start of summer it also means
the very official start of busy travel
although nate not right now apparently
yeah well it's quiet right now but mary
jane bell yes is live with a few things
you should think about before you hit
the road hey mary jane
good morning nate well 495 for gas here
on the gas station on reno and las vegas
boulevard and you know despite the high
gas prices triple a tells me that they
anticipate an increase in travel volume
john traynor from aaa says las vegas is
on the top of the list for memorial day
destination so expect plenty of traffic
and delays this weekend inflation has
bumped up the cost when it comes to food
hotels airfare and even gas prices so he
recommends travel insurance to cover up
unexpected delays or trip interruptions
and those we spoke to say gas prices
were not a deterrent to get them to
their favorite destination spot
aaa had wondered what gas prices were
going to do to the appetite for
traveling and what triple a found was
39.2 million americans are going to
travel this weekend 35 million are going
to do that by vehicle over in sac at
costco is like 560.
okay yeah about the same right it's
pretty it's about the same here in las
vegas but on your way up here
over at delano it was like 6 18.
peak travel times are usually in the
early afternoon so trainer recommends
leaving early in the morning if you can
to avoid traffic and remember
flexibility is key here so remember plan
ahead if you can as you head out to your
memorial day travel destination
reporting live mary jane bolleza live
local now plan